la protection
pour ce faire
james bond pour isoler j'en sais rien
elle est partie à cette vente de singles
et s'apprête à rentrer ils vont arracher
les portes et des fenêtres avec des
chaînes quoi tu habitais prison refuse
non j'avais tort je me suis complètement
trompé tu veux dire comment pas nous
livrer j'ai tu vas faire quoi
charles gervais c'est une écoute mon
écoute moi bien tiens tu vas pas le
mettre dehors non d'accord tu vas aller
de cachées dans le sous-sol et une en
sort sous aucun prétexte compris je
t'adore des supers à les courts accroît
pistoletto fils tu peux m'expliquer ce
qu'on va faire on va se battre